[Music]
[Applause]
I Can't Go For That no no
can do I Can't Go For That
you can do that's just a sample of what
Bring It Down The House of what
Connecticut who's going to hear maybe
eight days from now when Darius Rucker
comes to town I don't think tickets are
still available if they know this is
happening Darius has really gone radio
silent though I was reaching uh I was
reaching out to him and I didn't hear
back and I thought well there's this bet
uh the dolphins of course made him cry
and fritzy was going to get to sing two
Hall and Oates songs
and he would be the warm-up act or the
opener before the opening act for Darius
Rucker eight days from now Darius Rucker
joining us on the program
what would you like to say
lost by I lost the bet we're ready we're
ready okay now what does that mean
because if Todd is singing two Hall and
Oates songs
what role do you play
with Todd singing those songs when do
these songs happen first of all
uh we'll have to figure we'll have to
figure that out because I guess my
band's gonna have to play them right
because you know he needs back power
backup music right
yeah are you singing
I have to sing back up yeah of course
okay
when when does your band you got a great
band when does your band need to know
the songs that they're going to be
playing
like this afternoon
okay Todd
what do you want to play uh they would
be private eyes and kiss on my list from
Daryl Hall and John wow okay they got
work to do okay all right I'll let them
know that right now but but you've been
to Daryl's house then you go you played
music up there in his barn
um is there any chance that uh Hall and
Oates will be at the concert uh in eight
days
um there's a better chance of Jesus
being at the concert probably
okay I don't think so I don't think
they're gonna be there now okay is there
an opening act
uh yeah yeah uh Drew Davidson Drew
Holcomb and the neighbors yeah okay
where where is fritzy though is he
before them
he's gonna have to be somewhere like
around my set because uh you know my
band has to be on stage to play and
everything else being covered so yeah
it'll be it'll be more like around
mindset what would you give to get out
of this bet
nothing okay because I I I lost okay
because the other suggestion was that
Todd gets to hit you in the face with a
pie
oh is that what y'all really want to do
would you realize rather do that no no
no no no no
I I I'm worried about your career that's
all I just want
I want to make sure that this is a
positive for you I just wondered how
badly you want to get out of this
oh I'm good with it you know it's pretty
that has to be working man he's the one
that has a singles all those songs it's
always an easy to sing man okay but how
are you gonna what are you saying to the
audience see your warm-up Act is done
and then let's say
10 minutes before you're gonna go on
then you have to come out and say hey by
the way and then people go
oh there he is and then you go okay hold
on I'm bringing out a guy
I want to say I lost the bet to The Dan
Patrick Show here's frizzy out doing
these now
doing his uh his best
okay
yeah they're not going to know who he is
no no no no who you are though so that
you know I'll be kind of okay
think you should at least wear a shirt
a t-shirt you're always wearing a
t-shirt could you wear it that says
maybe our name's on it
wait a second he's got it I got a snake
and I gotta wear a t-shirt with your
face on it no not my face on
I have I have T-shirts you know what we
have a t-shirt with fritzy's face on it
okay well these things I'll wear that
okay all right so Todd we got to get one
of your t-shirts what are you a large
[Laughter]
you're gonna wish you had a large
no I'm not
I got these arms to be showing out there
come on man okay now as a dolphins fan
do you now hate Aaron Rodgers
you know we're playing we're playing
golf at Pebble and Aaron and I decided
we're gonna play together so we're
playing this year and the one thing I
said to him I said man you can go to
anybody you want you can't go to the gym
I think I'm going to the Jets I'm like
stop messing with me
so live and I are fighting right now for
sure we're fighting yeah because um yeah
we're fine Dalvin cook may be going to
the Jets so you've got a quarterback who
can't stay healthy he's taking what Jiu
Jitsu lessons and learning how to fall
hey Jujitsu let's teach them how to fall
so we don't get any concussions this
year we're winning the Super Bowl and
it's going to bring Aaron's heart okay
yeah
we can have another bet
no no no no
no more bets okay you're done okay I'm
done with that okay
um country music Mount Rushmore
oh goodness
okay Johnny Cash of course yep
uh Dolly Parton
uh uh goodness gracious what a great
question
um
probably George Strait no I don't think
I think I would think that uh Garth
Brooks would be on it before George
wow but but you're right probably George
Strait and uh probably George and uh and
William what about Willie
oh my goodness yeah
it's probably Willie is still available
yeah wow wow see that's hard that's a
hard question yeah I forgot about Dolly
because I mentioned this Hank Williams
Hank Williams Hank Williams how could I
how could I forget to put Hank Williams
on there yeah that's a hard question
right there have you gotten high with
Willie
yes very
how does that how does that work
s several times and he's always awesome
and the first time we met uh it was us
in the Dave Matthews Band and we're
meeting them at the same time and we all
walk up on this bus and we're sitting
there waiting for him and he sits down
and I'm talking about in 45 seconds
he rolled in the past seven
and 45 seconds just rolling pattern
rolling fast and we're looking at him
going what is
was his pot different and was his pot
different than you had
yes it was yes it was it was crazy yeah
it's willyweed yeah all right so uh a
week from tomorrow
you know the songs yep and then we'll
get there and does Todd need to is there
any warm-up I mean just let us know
because you got to do a show I'll let
you know because he he might get he
might have to come and sound check I'll
let him know
okay yeah Paulie yeah Dan that's my idea
years ago Todd bought a country outfit
with a hat a polo and a shirt from the
Boot Barn in San Bernardino California
playing with a country Legend like
Darius Ruckus seems like a perfect time
to wear that outfit
yeah
but you gotta see this outfit Darius you
know if you're all about content Darius
then you want him to wear the cowboy
outfit uh Todd would you be willing to
wear I think you should definitely wear
it for sure would you be willing to wear
the cowboy outfit I would it'll look
strange thing all I know it's but if
that's what you want me to wear that's
what I would I would wear wait to honor
Darius what Seton what's wrong God he
would walk straightly into like oncoming
traffic if you told him to
amazing moment for my friend dear and he
you and you guys are doing everything in
his power to make him look stupid let
alone he's got to get up there and sing
what are we doing he's gonna look great
I think he'll look awesome oh God I
think you'll look awesome you have your
boots on everybody's gonna have their
cowboy hats on everybody's going to be
in the mood and you're gonna go out
there and sing Hall of notes gonna have
his jeans tucked into his boots yeah I
think it's gonna
Darius is gonna be wearing your t-shirt
on stage
crazy this is gonna be a disaster and I
love it I love it
um
okay
um I'll be in touch you be in touch let
me know if Todd needs to go to sound
check because that what time is sound
check on uh next Friday yeah I will let
you know okay
like five o'clock four o'clock four
o'clock oh
yeah and then you start drinking after
that
well I'll be sleeping he'll be in town
okay yes you can watch Seton um can I
ask Darius real quick how long have you
been on tour like this current tour this
leg
uh this tour has been like two months
already two or three months oh so you've
so you've been at it a while already
okay any special guests as big as fritzy
you've been on tour with you like you on
a cameo no one ever nobody's bigger than
fritzy so no no one okay somebody close
to that
no nobody lives here we just been out
doing it so nobody just says hey you're
in my town I'm gonna come like Taylor
Swift always gets people to come up and
sing with her
[Laughter]
wait you went on stage with Taylor not
this tour but uh I think the last tour I
sang with her what did you sing
we did all right
oh okay yeah yeah that was cool but did
you want to do her song
no she called me up and said hey I want
to be in Columbia South Carolina please
come sing with me I said absolutely
that's pretty good man
yeah all right
um all right so uh it'll be a week from
tomorrow we'll be there wait till
tomorrow I'll keep in touch I'll let you
know what time all right but don't go
don't go radio silent on me when I reach
out to you and then I don't hear from
you
what are you talking about okay for a
day you didn't hear me no a couple of
days a couple of days and then even then
you sent me a message last night what
time like you didn't even like you
didn't even put a question mark after
what time you were like because you know
I'm in it sounded like you were angry
and then I you know and then Frenchy's
nervous and all right so we're all good
okay what am I ever angry
oh I've seen you angry before
you have
I I you know what I I saw you angry
remember when we played golf in Vegas
and uh and you lost to me
oh that made me angry yes yeah you
cheated no I didn't I I
played well I did I accidentally played
well but now that we're both on the pxg
team you know now I know now I got your
secret weapon by the way this is the uh
this is the t-shirt that you'll be
wearing if we can get a shot of
Frenchy's uh Paulie's holding it up here
can can you see that uh that's the
T-shirt
I'm excited thank you very much I'm
excited about that that is hot looking
I'm gonna look so good today
all right and we'll get you a medium
yeah it's medium okay all right uh thank
you bud we'll talk to you soon love you
brother all right that's Darius Rucker
that's Darius Rucker Don't Call Him
Hootie by the way just call him Darius
yes Seton you know I think had I known
that Darius has been on the road already
for two or three months he's probably
looking for something to spice the night
up obviously he wants Todd now to come
on stage to do a couple of songs makes
sense if I was gonna spice up my tour I
don't think I'd have it
yeah yeah
all right you're singing two Hall and
Oates songs you have to go for Sound
Check Yes we will okay pretty crazy
songs